now okay so it's time to take a trip to
selfie world we announced the recent
grand opening
of the interactive diy photography
studio in town square
just last week and of course we had to
go and see it for ourselves
rocky theas is there live to show us how
to utilize the space and of course
get that perfect shot right
[Music]
that is right christian okay so this is
one of the areas here and there are 22
booths
in all of selfie world here in vegas
it's their biggest one to date
and we get it right here at town square
so i have a few pictures that i took
if you could pop those up so i could
show off my skills a little bit just
because i had a lesson
from a few gin zeirs okay those are the
ones who
you know the trendsetters the cool ones
the young ones that we have to learn
from
so thank you so much for joining us
kaylee who is a local influencer
and marissa who's her cousin and her
photographer okay this is teamwork this
is a family
affair here so we want to talk about
because we talked about lighting
and how important that is in the last
one and they every time you come in and
you make a reservation
you get a ring light to take with you
around the place so that's really cool
and then of course the next thing are
angles right
how important are angles and how do you
do it come set us up um okay
so there's like multiple angles that you
can take pictures from
i usually just base it on their poses
and like what flatters their
like the way they look and like things
like that
but lighting is really hard because like
as you can see that sign
like if i go over here right so you want
to be careful when there's a neon sign
with the ring light because the
reflection gets in the way
right so like if i take a picture i can
show you look at that can you see the
perfect so like you can see it on the
the sign and that's like not something
you want it can like mess up the picture
interesting and with this one i like i
like this booth in particular because
it has the the gate right or the cell so
this the bars
actually kind of creates a really cool
angle right yeah so if i wanted to take
a picture from that angle i would move
the led light or the ring right you guys
are getting a
personal lesson here from ginzi right
now okay this is rare
i would take the picture and i have the
settings customized
on my phone so i have it at a 16-3 ratio
and then plus three exposure to like
brighten up the picture
so it's not so dim okay are you guys
taking notes seriously okay come on come
over here you guys because i want to
show
another another booth that kind of gives
you a different perspective
kaylee and i are going to sit down here
as the
models okay and this is a two this is a
pair shot
but marissa has a secret to getting the
shot
and it has to do with video not still
photo right right so explain that
concept
okay so the camera on your phones
takes good pictures but in videos it's
in 4k
okay so you get a better quality photo
and live photos are way easier to take
in a video
portion like in a video wow look at and
look how
look at the position okay she is
squatting this is hard work
you make your you make your cousin and
your photographer work for you girl oh
yes
for like an hour and a half last time
i feel like this is a sport coming into
selfie world you got to be a little
athletic to get these angles and these
and these photos right
so what she said if you didn't hear you
do your photos on a video
and then you screenshot the video for
your favorite shots right
because when it's still photos you're
stuck with the one face with the video
you could be
mid pose and you would like it better
than the actual pose wow so
that's what we do and it just we get a
bunch more pictures that way
oh my gosh look mind blown okay i'm
taking all the notes coming up later in
the four o'clock though
we want to show off not just the photo
booth here but also the really great
story too so stay tuned for that
right and rocky before you go christian
producer adriana and i want to know how
many pictures have you taken so far
oh my gosh way too many i'm embarrassed
all right wait too many we'll check back
with her in a little bit christian
keep taking those notes all that stuff's
way over my head
goodness